CHRISTINE BREINER:
Welcome to recitation.
Today what I'd like us to do is
look at the inequality tangent
x bigger than x for the x-values
between 0 and pi over 2.
We want to show that
that is definitely true
using the mean value theorem.
And I want to point out that
this was actually something
that Joel used when he
was a graphing tangent x
and arctangent x on
the same xy-plane.
He used this fact in order to
get the right-looking graph.
So what I'd like
you to do, again,
is I want you to show that for
any x between 0 and pi over 2,
tangent x is bigger than x.
And use the mean value
theorem to do it.
I'll give you a little time to
think about it, to work on it,
and then I'll be back
and we'll do it together.
OK.
Welcome back.
So I'm going to take us
through how to do this problem.
And what I want to do
is I want to point out
a few things initially.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to remind us of the form
of the mean value theorem
that we need.
And the form that
we need will be
f of x is equal to f of a plus
f prime of c times x minus a.
And here, remember, c has
to be between a and x.
So in this case, what we want
to consider is the region from 0
up to some x-value.
So always, this is, if you
think about it, the a and the x,
well, a will be 0 and x will be
the right-hand region, always
less than pi over 2.
So what we need to
check is, I'm going
to consider f of
x equal tangent x.
And what I need to
consider is, does tangent x
satisfy the hypotheses
of the mean value theorem
on the region of interest?
And so our region of interest
will always be a equals 0
and b is equal to x, which
is less than some pi over 2.
And it is true, tangent
x is continuous between 0
and any value less
than pi over 2.
And it's also
differentiable between 0
and any value less
than pi over 2.
So I can apply the mean
value theorem to tangent x.
So in order to do this
now, what I'd like to see
is what kind of things I
need for the right-hand side
of this equation.
So I obviously need to
know what the output is
at a, which is equal to 0.
So let's recall f of 0.
Well, tangent 0 is 0-- it's sine
of 0 divided by cosine of 0.
And then I need to evaluate the
derivative somewhere between a,
which is 0, and pi over 2.
x can be any value
less than pi over 2.
So let's evaluate what the
derivative is in terms of x.
We did this, actually,
in another recitation.
The derivative of tangent
x is secant squared x.
And so now let's
plug in what we know
and then see what else
we need to do in order
to finish solving this problem.
OK.
So what we have.
f of x, I'm actually
going to write tangent x,
so we can see what's
happening here.
f of x is tangent x, and
then I have that that equals,
well, f of a is 0, plus
f prime evaluated at c--
so that's going to be secant
squared c-- times x minus a.
Well, a here is 0, so
this is just times x.
So we're very close.
We're very close
to showing tangent
x is always bigger than x.
In fact, you can see very
easily what ultimately we
need to show.
We just need to show that secant
squared c is bigger than 1
in our region of interest.
And that would do
it, because then this
would be bigger than 1 times x.
The right-hand side
would be bigger than 1 times
x, so that would be sufficient.
So let's make sure
we understand what
secant squared c can look like.
Or what the values can be.
So we have c is between 0 and
x, which is less than pi over 2.
Right?
That's where c is.
So we always need
to remember what
values c could possibly have.
And then let's think about
what we know about secant of c,
there.
Well, secant of c is equal
to 1 over cosine of c.
So if you can't remember
what secant's values are,
think about the values
of cosine in that region.
So I'm going to draw a rough
sketch of the value of cosine
between 0 and pi over 2.
The value of cosine does
something like this.
This is 0, this is pi over 2.
This is a very rough sketch.
But this output is 1.
So between 0 and pi
over 2, cosine of c
is always less than 1.
So 1 over cosine of c
is always bigger than 1.
OK?
Because we're taking
that reciprocal value.
So again, cosine of c from 0
to pi over 2, not including 0,
is always strictly less than 1.
And so 1 over cosine c is
always strictly greater than 1.
And so now I have
the information
I need to come back
and finish the problem.
So again, we were looking
at the expression,
we have tangent x is equal
to secant squared c times x.
Well, now I know secant
c is bigger than 1,
so now I know this whole
thing is bigger than 1 times
x, which is just equal to x.
So if you noticed,
on the left-hand side
we have a tangent
x equals something
which is bigger than x.
So we've just shown that,
for any value of x between 0
and pi over 2, tangent
x is bigger than x.
And I think we'll stop there.